[Music]
and give a back news submitted by I'm
from Canada
hey what about to say ABC a after the
end that's the Canadian mating home a
grandma was told by police to return the
balls that were kicked into her yard or
else she could be charged with then why
she keep involved why should keep
involved but they kicked the ball into
her yard give them back we got yours now
no what are you serious yes was it lower
if something came into my property it is
now mine so what Charles walks onto your
property did yours hell yeah ok [ __ ]
what I have it used to tell if a dog
walks into your yard times I try to keep
every dollar I was my your girl one I
want to give it back not bringing read
that's how he's not bringing no she
didn't walk into her yard walked into
our gym she didn't walk into our gym I
was proactive so you walk another
person's yard I took their dog yeah I
think you stole her I did steal her what
they didn't wonder you can't steal
something that was unwanted they left
her there to die can you feel the
neglected things yeah I think so if
someone doesn't use a lot more I could
take it go to their shed and take their
lot more you win the last time you
[ __ ] mowed your lawn well what about
us to have a classic car and it's just
parks on them it's neglected what have
they been working on it but they don't
drive it well I mean no that's not
neglected then like they're washing it
working on it fine but if it's been and
if you're not gonna [ __ ] take care of
your [ __ ] I'm taking it so it's just
abandoned home
Yuri yep your kids neglect your kids
mine taking them mine you under your job
my job I'm gonna start sweeping floors
[ __ ] balls kicked over somebody
else's yard or going over a fence
reminds me a lot of my childhood what
you guys used to do when their ball went
over to a neighbor's yard climb builder
go over as you just climb alright yeah
so none of you guys went over and
knocked on the door and ask for
permission rooms door back
depends if I know the neighbor yeah but
usually our neighbors are out in the
backyard and so we were just asking if
they can just throw it back to us and we
just say sorry
I usually climbed over and if I saw
someone in there I call them back over
and knock on the door yeah
I don't want to get caught Hemme what
happened to that name 73 years old
usually given to dogs now so what about
Hennessey pay me that is like 1 cent
right one penny per dog she was fitted
visited by officers she was she was
visited by officers who told her that if
she keeps the balls from the neighbor
from the kids next door that she would
be charged with that Finders Keepers
[ __ ] Westside England this is
such a safe neighborhood that the cops
had time to come over and say stop
[ __ ] keeping the balls you old hag so
you don't [ __ ] talk to me like that
[ __ ]
because if anybody turned to 1/4 than a
quarter bag not give a face to penthouse
well she looks great
she looks like a [ __ ] you yeah what kind
of [ __ ] bother you this is my ball
she looks like the guy from Nightmare
Before Christmas Jack Skellington oh I
just could have the lighting it's not a
soccer ball basketball soccer ball here
put these on you see the really fun tiny
woman the bulky oh yeah that's why I was
like that balls [ __ ] it's precise
because it's quote look at my hand looks
bigger opposed to this one your head is
always big hey there has pretty big hey
where did you come from because you said
it very good so this is like the
trampoline no this is the labor ohh oh
my god oh it's like a trampoline you get
a picture like on the trevally
everything all right
I got a soccer goal and then they got a
trampoline well I would jump all that
and do flying kicks into the [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh hell no the fencing is yeah so I
guess I think from what I see in in the
UK well I would do that too that's it
really nice backyard well what does she
get the bucket she didn't know which way
was [ __ ] flying in from
shinji me alchemist action ship and come
over knock on a door say please can I
have a ball back well how did that
happen though know this is what happened
kid kick the ball over right from London
oh you've done this about seven times
today and this my Romanians could live
in London - mother - piece of [ __ ] or
the ball came over his master [ __ ]
flowers she would not a petunia I have
to feel so bad when my toys flew over
and smashed the neighbours flowers and
plants uh-huh I didn't mean to do it
what did you don't like a [ __ ] try
set a circle over it
no but sometimes you just thought you're
just playing yes close man it [ __ ] flies
over and then a smashes [ __ ] what should
be zooming yeah Art's right so a lot of
these balls were destroying her guard
Angie but that's not cool okay I
understand though because we used to
play basketball in front of mrs. Spears
this place right
and every time they'd be some new
[ __ ] that becoming to the
basketball courts we'd be like y'all
don't [ __ ] up mrs. Spears as flowers
these [ __ ] just be rolling the
ball like y'all be gentle [ __ ] up the
flower mrs. Pierce guarding and we
always say don't [ __ ] with mrs. Pierce
flowers don't [ __ ] with Miss penny
flowers so she's saying that last year
she held on to the ball that there were
up to 10 balls in her shed not so mean
much lady because she wanted to teach
the kids that there were consequences
for being kids and having a good time
and not having their faces [ __ ] glued
to a laptop or a [ __ ] phone but they
are also [ __ ] up or flowers just
complete disregard for her garden it's
funny cuz usually word is that but this
time in jail what what happened Joseph
in your logic is known for its logic in
terms of like defending like the like
the kids for being destructive for being
too short know it I mean kids will be
kids yeah but it doesn't pay back the
hard work and time spent on the road is
if you had a fall planet in their
backyard Nash in the glass yeah
mastering over your porcelain figurines
knocking a girl over are you gonna be
like careful be kid
no I probably be like yo kids um like
talk to the parents okay your kids
pretty sure they did that because
there's ten balls that pull over so will
you still say kids will be kids I don't
know I just think it sucks come out
balls right yeah then they get a pellet
gun for Christmas this will be a pellet
flying over and then your house is going
to be under attack then they turn 21 it
sandy bullets hey [ __ ] oh yeah I
stopped it overnight entire house is
demolished you got me at the bullets
didn't have anywhere to live and she was
saying that when she held on to all
those ball she said that no one ever
came to ask for them to redeem them
retrieve them if she worked with the
parents and the kids [ __ ] up the
garden they should come and fix it
exactly
I think I would say you play as much as
you want outside but there's you know if
you [ __ ] up other people's property or
things you just have to go over there
and do work if you [ __ ] up my Gardens
I'm gonna [ __ ] in your hands and you
have to put the fertilizer on the debt I
will just create a gate for the wall
it's like a whenever you guys kick my
[ __ ] over and you bust it you gotta fix
it and then you could take your ball
back it's - come here spread your butt
cheeks [ __ ] on a death could they
destroyed the soil or color God
nutrients you know Laurie we should make
it in your scenario proposal always
ladies plague 11 fingers naked kids
other [ __ ] have you seen my baby
pictures I'm naked in all of them yeah
I'm very very angry we bring so much
honestly my mind she's a gangster okay
yeah what Bo I gotta put so much work
into this garden we are both in our mid
seventies it's not as if we are bitter
and twisted old so-and-so's no we'd like
to get home okay we'd like to get on
with our neighbors we are reasonable
people and our parents and our parents
ourselves yeah so she's saying like I'm
girl okay yeah so the neighbor was
interviewed as well she doesn't want to
be named but her children aged 11 and 6
are too scared to go over and retrieve
them from her apparently such a big
bunch of [ __ ]
so apparently with his neighbors danger
that penny is actually a mean-ass old
lady so she's like I don't send them
around anymore she's a bit rude I'm
scared of her I'm not sending my
children that reminds me of the family
yeah and they're enabling that be here
by buying them more balls yeah yeah so
many balls in the throw over to the
neighbors I would make the kids go over
if do you want balls I'm not buying you
any balls you go over there and you face
your fears yeah yeah that's what I was
used to because at the end of the day
that old grandmas not going to beat
their ass well I'm she better not or
else we're gonna beat her ass but I
think I think that's a good lesson to
teach the kid where there's not the
world isn't full of nice people
sometimes you have to deal with mean
people and if you want to get your ball
back you have to go there and talk to
them in a go share with them yeah it's
like look here you know this is like
Bowser okay you got to go over and
defeat Bowser that ugly [ __ ] turtle
man and if you don't you don't win the
princess hello my mother Joe Malians
please like the video and for more
beautiful videos look up there
[Music]